merci monsieur le président madame la
première vie nice mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je dois
vous dire madame la première ministre
que j'ai été émue en entendant vos
propos concernant le sénat
il faut dire qu'ici faisons partie d'une
communauté martyrisé qui a pas eu
souvent l'occasion
d'entendre des ministres et encore moins
première ministre s'exprimer avec autant
de tendresse vis-à-vis de nous
j'avais l'impression
j'avais l'impression d'être dans un
monde metaverse et je me dis c'est pas
possible alors je suis sûr madame la
première mini ce que vous allez
apprécier le sénat
après quelques passages à l'assemblée
nationale que vous avez inauguré
aujourd'hui
tel ulysse chahuté par la tempête les
rivages de la haute assemblée vont vous
semblez particulièrement paisible
madame la première ministre beaucoup
vous connaissent ici comme une
interlocutrice attentive et je formule
le voeu que matignon n'était en rien
entamé vos qualités d'écouté de dialogue
car de l'équipe qu'il va en falloir les
électeurs ont opté pour le grand
chamboule tout institutionnels ils ont
ressuscité la république parlementariste
de 1958 dans la république
présidentialiste de 1962 consolidé en
2009 ils ont imposé un indispensable
dialogue entre les forces politiques en
remettant le parlement au centre du jeu
la disruption à la mode en 2017 est
synonyme de catastrophe cinq ans plus
tard beaucoup crient à la faillite des
institutions il convoque parfois le
spectre de l'immobilisme du blocage de
la parade ici que se passe-t-il de si
grave pour que certains s'en inquiètent
la majorité présidentielle où il n'a
plus la majorité elle ne détient que 44
% des sièges à l'assemblée nationale
j'observe pour autant que le spd du
chancelier kohl scholtes n'en a que 28 %
au bundestag et que le pse de pedro
sanchez n'en a que 34 % aux cortès
madame la première ministre pourquoi
serions nous les seuls à ne pas savoir
rechercher des compromis désaccord pour
aboutir
[Applaudissements]
au fond cette situation peut surprendre
c'est la situation normale en démocratie
représentative est sans doute allons
nous découvrir que le parlementarisme
peut très bien fonctionner et même être
vertueux car il nous forcera à légiférer
- pour légiférer mieux par exemple sans
ordonnance à condition
à condition de se désintoxiquer du fait
majoritaire et de ses facilités
autrement dit ne plus considérer des
assemblées comme des chambres
d'enregistrement d'un régime
présidentiel
et parallèlement mais cela a été dit par
les orateurs précédents ne pas
contourner ou dévaloriser ces mêmes
assemblées en multipliant des comités
théodule les députés et les sénateurs
ont la légitimité du suffrage universel
le cee dans la constitution et les ceser
représentent les forces vives du pays la
constitution nous offre toutes les
institutions nécessaires pour débattre
pas besoin d'un probable convention
citoyenne aussitôt constitué aussitôt
congédié source de confusion un
parlement fort
un parlement fort n'a pas besoin des
racks oui à la convention transpartisane
pour les institutions non au conseil de
la refondation
je fais
je fais le pari qu'un parlement vivant
créatif sera le meilleur vecteur
pourrait intéresser les français à la
vie politique du moins en forme le voeu
car je n'oublie pas que plus d'un an
inscrits sur deux n'est pas allé voter
et que la représentation issu des
élections est certes bien plus conforme
à celle du corps électoral mais n'est
pas encore totalement proportionnelle
pour que le parlementarisme fonctionne
de nouveau il faut que l'exécutif
apprennent à être plus constructif ce
que nous faisons au sénat depuis bien
longtemps madame la première ministre
bienvenue dans notre monde cet esprit
constructif que vous revendiquez nous
l'avons toujours pratiqué même si
certains prétendent ne s'en est jamais
rendu compte nous avons seulement été
une assemblée qui devait régulièrement
défendre son existence mais depuis que
vous avez parlé on a retiré des sacs de
sable aux fenêtres voilà
qui avait le culot de faire des
propositions et de contrôler l'action de
l'exécutif qui était tellement
intolérante que les deux tiers des
projets de lois ont été adoptées avec
notre soutien qui était tellement
intransigeant que nous avons voté toutes
les lois d'urgence sanitaire la recette
est simple concernés présentent
concertée très en amont proposé concédé
et écouter le terrain au fond nous
n'avons pas le choix nos concitoyens ne
supporte plus la verticalité
jupitérienne mais nos taureaux
tolérerons pas non plus l'inaction et
ils auront raison compte tenu de la
situation du pays l'immobilisme est un
luxe dont nous n'avons pas les moyens
les campagnes présidentielle et
législatives n'ont pas permis de faire
émerger un véritable projet nous
découvrons aujourd'hui les intentions de
votre gouvernement voici quelques
considérations auxquelles notre groupe
est attaché la situation sociale est
explosive
elle a été contenue par un quoi qu'il en
coûte parmi les plus généreux de la
planète mais l'inflation surtout
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie a
de quoi remettre de ce aux poudres
la répartition des richesses des
richesses est choquant nos concitoyens
ne supporte plus les inégalités et
l'inde essence de certains privilégiés
nous proposerons de taxer les super
profits générés par la crise pétrolière
nos services publics
écoles hôpitaux sont dégradées vous
l'avais dit après des années de croyance
qu'un bon budget est un budget aux
moyens accrus pour faire très simple
nous n'avons pas de divergences notables
sur les sujets de politique étrangère
d'ambition européenne de défense
nationale sur l'avenir de la nouvelle
calédonie sur la violence qui affleure
partout dans la société nous prenons
acte de votre volonté d'agir encore plus
et toujours plus
quant à la désertification médicale dont
vous venez de parler la traiter par la
seule prévention ne suffira pas des
réformes de structure s'impose et je
pense notamment au rapport de mon ami
mort et et à ses conclusions qui ont
permis de réfléchir à la régulation de
l'installation des médecins comme cela
se pratique en allemagne depuis
longtemps l'un des rares sujets ayant
émergé des campagnes et celui des
retraites et nous approuvons la
nécessité d'une réforme vous avez
habilement évité de citer un âge de
départ à la retraite tout en mentionnant
la cité la part dont la nécessité de
travailler plus pour nous le paramètre
juste et celui de la durée de cotisation
dans un régime assurantiel c'est bien
lui qui détermine le niveau des droits
c'est dans cette direction que nous vous
proposerons d'année cette réforme est
susceptible d'intervenir alors que la
situation budgétaire du pays est
extrêmement préoccupante mais nos moyens
d'action sont amputés il n'est pas
envisageable d'augmenter les
prélèvements il faut donc agir sur les
dépenses soutenir le pouvoir d'achat
bien sûr à condition de n'aider que ceux
qui en ont impérativement besoin et de
commencer à faire des économies
correspondante l'illusion de l'argent
magique ne doit pas perdurer notamment
au détriment des collectivités locales
elles ne doivent plus servir de variable
d'ajustement par exemple la suppression
annoncée de la redevance télévision ne
peut pas se faire au prix d'une ponction
sur les dotations des collectivités
territoriales
[Applaudissements]
puisque nous cherchons des économies
acceptant d'être moins pointilleux sur
les normes qui souvent contraignent nos
collectivités enfin nous partageons
votre regard sur l'état de la planète le
réchauffement climatique l'effondrement
de la biodiversité les pollutions en
tout genre comme vous nous considérons
que la décroissance n'est plus une
option c'est socialement et humainement
impraticable en france et partout
ailleurs nous croyons la puissance de
l'innovation pour sortir par le haut des
contradictions de notre modèle mais
comme vous l'avez dit nous ne pourrons
pas le faire sans le nucléaire la crise
ukrainienne là encore cruellement
rappelé nous ne pouvons que nous en
réjouir mais nous ne sommes pas pour
autant sorti de l'ambigüité six paires
en projet ferme c'est peu il va falloir
aller plus loin par ailleurs la
limitation de la part du nucléaire à 50
% du mix électrique est toujours de mise
enfin il faudra sûrement prolonger les
réacteurs actuels les plus le plus
possible comme aux états unis faute de
quoi il nous faudra recourir au gaz ou
même au charbon comme en témoigne la
réouverture de saint-avold et donc
faillir à nos obligations de réduction
d'émissions carbone dans le même esprit
de responsabilité de réalisme nous
entendons la nécessité de limiter
l'artificialisation des terres mais nous
nous opposons totalement à une approche
dogmatique qui fige les territoires les
décrets d'application de la loi climat
et résilience sont inapplicables et
inacceptable pour beaucoup d'élus par
exemple il est absurde que des grands
travaux d'intérêt national cannibalise
le potentiel d'artificialisation de
toute une région vous doivent être
versés dans une enveloppe nationale qui
opère une péréquation
en un mot ce qu'il faut retravailler
d'urgence et en concertation avec les
collectivités
ce n'est pas l'objectif de la zad mais
les moyens d'y parvenir je donnais les à
madame la première me disent que
quelques exemples des dossiers qui nous
attendent les plus en vue pour illustrer
d'état d'esprit qui nous anime rares
madame la première ministre vous avez
dit que vous aviez une boussole bâtir
pour le pays
certains plusieurs rudik moir ont
convoqué le général de gaulle d'autres
l'esprit boulanger avec les miettes et
le pain
vous me permettrait de terminer en
faisant une invocation et en citant un
autre un auteur que nous aimons au sénat
le président larcher nous le disons
mais oui
c'est mieux ici
nous ne disons jamais où il par
discipline et non par dogmatisme donc
vous avez bien compris que nous
souhaitons travailler dans l'intérêt du
pays et chaque fois que vous voudrez
bien nous travaillons avec cet état
d'esprit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]